so you write that the single greatest
risk this is the risk you're most
convinced by the single greatest risk of
AI is that China wins Global AI
dominance and we the United States and
the West do not can you elaborate yeah
so this is the other thing which is a
lot of the sort of AI risk debates today
sort of assume that we're the only game
in town right and so we have the ability
to kind of sit in the United States and
criticize ourselves and you know have
our government like you know beat up on
our companies and figure out a way to
restrict what our companies can do and
you know we're gonna you know we're
gonna ban this and ban that restrict
this and do that and then there's this
like other like force out there that
like doesn't believe we have any power
over them whatsoever and they have no
desire to sign up for whatever rules we
decide to put in place
um and they're going to do whatever it
is they're going to do and we have no
control over it at all
and it's China and specifically the
Chinese Communist Party
um and they have a completely publicized
open you know uh plan for what they're
going to do with AI and it is not what
we have in mind
um and not only do they have that as a
vision and a plan for their society but
they also have it as a vision and plan
for the rest of the world so their plan
is what surveillance yeah authoritarian
control so authoritarian population
control
um you know good old-fashioned communist
authoritarian control
um and surveillance and enforcement
um and social credit scores and all the
rest of it
um and you are going to be monitored and
metered within an inch of everything all
the time
um and it's you know basically the end
of human freedom and that's their goal
and you know they justify it on the
basis of that's what leads to peace and
you're worried that the uh
regulating in the United States will
will call progress enough to where uh
the Chinese government would win that
race so their plan yeah yes yes and the
reason for that is they and again
they're very public on this they have
their plan is to prolifer their their
approach around the world and they have
this program called the digital Silk
Road right which is building on their
their Silk Road investment program and
they've got their they've been laying
they've been laying networking
infrastructure all over the world with
their 5G right work with their company
Huawei and so they've been laying all
this fabric but financial and
technological fabric all over the world
and their plan is to roll out their
vision of AI on top of that and to have
every other country be running their
version and then if you're a country
prone to you know authoritarianism
you're going to find this to be an
incredible way to become more
authoritarian uh if you're a country by
the way not prone authoritarianism
you're going to have the Chinese
Communist Party running your
infrastructure and having back doors
into it right which is also not good now
what's your sense of where they stand in
terms of the race towards super
intelligence as compared to the United
States yeah so good news is they're
behind but bad news is they you know
they let's just say they get access to
everything we do
um so they're probably a year behind at
each point in time but they get you know
downloads I think of basically all of
our work on a regular basis through a
variety of means
um and they are you know we'll see
they're at least putting out reports of
very just put out a report last week of
a gpg 3.5 analog
um they put up this report forget what
it's called but um they put out this
report of the cell and they did and they
you know the way when openai you know
puts out they they one of the ways they
test you know GPT um is they they run it
through standardized exams like the sat
right just how you can kind of get how
smart it is uh and so the Chinese report
they ran their LM through uh the Chinese
equivalent of the SAT
um and it includes a section on Marxism
um and a section on Mouse thought and it
turns out their AI does very well on
both of those topics right
so like uh this this alignment thing
communist AI right like literal
communist AI right and so their vision
is like that's the you know so you know
you could just imagine like you're a
school you know you're a kid 10 years
from now in Argentina or in Germany or
in who knows where uh Indonesia and you
ask they I'd explain to you like how the
economy works and it gives you the most
cheery upbeat explanation of Chinese
style communism you've ever heard right
so
like the stakes here are like really big
well my as we've been talking about my
hope is not just for the United States
but it would just uh the kit in his
basement or the open source LM because I
I don't know if I
um trust large centralized institutions
with super powerful Ai No matter what
their ideology is a power corrupts